Donald Trump's reaction
to the Twitter files is as you can
imagine
completely and totally unhinged Trump
not on Twitter by the way the irony of
that but on his own platform truth
social putting together a very long list
a list of wacky posts and explosions
some of which we will talk about in more
detail but you have to get a look at
what Donald Trump started saying so
Trump's starting with wow that's a
really big story about Twitter and
various forms of government fraud
including specifically election fraud
the same level of fraud took place with
the other big tech companies if not even
worse if that's possible we are living
in a very corrupt country and as they
are saying all over the Internet nothing
will be done about it because the
justice department and FBI are totally
corrupt but they'll keep investigating
boxes that were legally and openly taken
from the White House Trump trying to
make it seem as though the real crimes
like those exposed by the Twitter files
aren't being investigated of course no
such crimes were exposed Trump then
saying Trump was right again on 2020
election most used statement
Trump then saying so with the revelation
of massive and widespread fraud and
deception and working closely with big
tech companies the DNC and the Democrat
Party do you throw the presidential
election results of 2020 out and declare
the rightful winner or do you have a new
election we're going to get back to that
one because that one is so crazy and
insane Trump continuing again Trump was
right again on 2020 election most you
statement
Biden cheated Trump won memes retweets
retroths returned the Diamonds the world
is laughing at the United States of
America and its corrupt and rigged
presidential election of 2020 folks it's
almost 2023.
unprecedented fraud requires
unprecedented cure
I wonder what Mitch McConnell the rhinos
and all of the weak Republicans who
couldn't get the presidential of 20
presidential election of 2020 approved
and out of the way fast enough are
thinking now they are a disgrace to our
great party and our nation which has
become a laughing stock all over the
world then just retweeting and posting
about I mean just spending endless
amounts of time on truth so social truth
Central election interference at a level
never seen before truth social is so hot
even the fake and disgusting news media
is in agreement on that etc etc
this guy has only one hammer and that
hammer is the hammer of I really won the
election and everything is just about
how I won
and how unfairly I am treated I'm the
ultimate victim that is ultimately
Trump's message and the most important
thing he wants to get across for the
most part this is another one of those
unhinged Rants and screeds because he's
Furious that people aren't praying at
his Altar and deferential enough to him
but there is one piece in there that is
particularly horrifying completely
unconstitutional which is demanding
apparently based on the Twitter Story
the Twitter files which we already said
are really no big story
that he be reinstated as president of
the United States we're going to deal
with that specifically a little bit
later in the show make sure that you are
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com
slash the davidpackman show I do have
covid my voice is a little messed up
bear with me the show continues